il l'a appelé routine mais en réalité ça
montre n'a rien d'un défi ordinaire
florian jeune ingénieur de 28 ans avait
décidé de faire une vraie montre
françaises labellisées origine france
garantie quand je présente mon projet il
ya deux ans les gens me disent ouais le
made in france florian ça coûte très
cher aujourd'hui il suffit d'assembler
en france pour que les montrent que les
montres se vendent pas besoin d'avoir
une démarche jusqu'au boutiste et puis
en fait aujourd'hui je démontre un petit
peu le contraire ça montre sera vendu
295 euros est bel et bien fabriquer de
86 % de composants français 13 des 14
fournisseurs de florian sont en france
dont neuf en franche comté au moins
coiffe est aussi français au sens qu'il
est même assemblée en france à partir de
nombreux composants français tout à fait
c'est un bouillonnement et c'est vrai
qu'on est ravi de mettre en relation
nous des jeunes créateurs comme ça avec
des fabricants des fournisseurs tout ça
pour les aider à accélérer un petit peu
les choses
eux aussi ont décidé de créer une
nouvelle marque du très haut de gamme
entièrement dessinés et fabriqués ici à
palente à deux pas de l'ancien site lipp
à l'origine du projet ces deux hommes
l'un designer chez peugeot l'autre
ingénieur horloger côté suisse le
résultat c'est une montre qui évoque
l'automobile et relève de vrais défis
techniques à l'image des aiguilles qu'il
a fallu plier pour arriver à nos fins on
devait avoir une aiguille qui était avec
un seul pli aucun sous-traitant suisse
ne pouvait nous faire ou français ne
pouvait nous faire ses aiguilles donc on
a décidé de les faire en interne c'est à
dire que même en a rajouté une
complexité on a fait deux plis et c'est
l'horloger maxime qui clients internes
un horloger de haut vol qui a fait le
choix de quitter la grande maison suisse
qui l'employait pour mettre en oeuvre le
projet des deux associés seront tous une
idée de
d'aventurés de participer à quelque
chose et puis refaire un peu renaître
d'horlogerie en france c'est quelque
chose qui me tenait vraiment à coeur
cinq montres par mois sortiront de
l'atelier à 55000 euros pièce hors taxes
le côté français
se retrouvent dans cette audace à la
fois esthétique et à la fois stylistique
et c'est pour ça qu'à un moment donné on
a probablement le fait le choix d'être
de ce côté là de la frontière et de
revendiquer comme une marque de luxe
éminemment design éminemment stylistique
mais avec une cohérence technique
une audace qui a déjà séduit à londres
singapour ou paris
des clients très riche qui attendaient
qu'on les surprennent